[Música]
volvemos a Francia porque transcurre la
nueva jornada de huelga general y en
France 24 hacemos el cubrimiento los
sindicatos no dan el brazo a torcer con
la reforma de las pensiones pero tampoco
lo hace el gobierno de Manuel macron
tras adoptar el aumento de la edad de
jubilación con el mecanismo 49.3 sin
votación en la asamblea nacional Pero a
qué costo El Ejecutivo planea seguir
impulsando su agenda de reformas
incluido un texto sobre migración y que
ha sido además muy criticado por la
oposición la duda es si el mandatario
hallará el capital político para navegar
en el parlamento vamos a hacer el
análisis con vs quienes analista
internacional y profesor de relaciones
internacionales en la pontificia
universidad javeriana de Bogotá además
experto en francofonía y en relaciones
exteriores francesas con ese
recibimiento Gracias por estar en France
24 y en directo América Buenos días
está Emmanuel macron condenado al
inmovilismo como le preguntaron durante
la entrevista que concedió la semana
pasada en televisión nacional si se
encuentra en carroom sin salida con esta
reforma de las funciones tiene una mayor
ya relativa en el parlamento y además
han dicho que ya no van a usar más el
artículo
409.3 Más allá de leyes de finanzas
entonces va a tener mucha dificultad en
sacar nuevas leyes nuevos proyectos en
este contexto en el cual su gobierno y
su persona son muy impopulares bueno
ustedes decía que tiene una mayoría
relativa en el parlamento pero la
mayoría absoluta pues es algo que no
existe en el congreso necesitará macron
como en el caso de la Reforma de las
pensiones un apoyo de otros grupos como
los republicanos para llevar adelante de
otras iniciativas en su gobierno aún así
no está garantizado que le espera en el
parlamento por ejemplo la reforma de la
migración por hablar de lo más cercano
que hoy debía presentarse pero que fue
aplazada en vista la situación que hay
en las calles y pues también a nivel
político Sí el único apoyo que podría
tener es por parte de los republicanos
el partido de derecha sin embargo este
partido es muy dividido hay incluso
algunos diputados que votaron la moción
de censura Y entonces Dentro de este
partido no existe un consenso para
ayudar a maco es incluso puede haber más
divisiones dentro del campo de Macro
porque hay un pequeño partido político
dentro de la coalición de Macro el
movimiento de los demócratas que pilló
responder a la propuesta de los
sindicatos de realizar una mediación y
de hablar sobre una eventual suspensión
de la reforma sobre las pensiones
asumiendo que la reforma para la
migración siguiera su paso hacia el
parlamento Tan pronto se calme un poco
la situación en las calles si se logra
calmar la situación en las calles usted
como ve la posibilidad de esta reforma
llamada para controlar la inmigración y
mejorar la integración porque la
oposición lo que dice desde la izquierda
es que desmaterializa los trámites y los
lugares donde se pueden pedir los
documentos es decir que deshumaniza
mucho el proceso migratorio Cuál es la
expectativa del gobierno Pues con esta
reforma que ya desde ya antes de ser
presentada eso es duramente criticada Sí
el tema migratorio siempre provoca mucha
polarización y va a haber entonces
críticas por parte de la izquierda pero
críticas tomen por parte del partido de
extrema derecha de la reagrupación
nacional Entonces el espacio político va
a ser muy estrecho y de hecho yo creo
que no va este tema no va a volver como
prioridad en dentro de los próximos días
próximas semanas porque el espacio para
votar y para adoptar esta reforma es muy
estrecho bueno y en los titulares de hoy
lo que hemos visto es que macron es
tímidamente parece que está empezando a
ofrecer la mano para buscar que
finalicen las protestas A qué se refiere
esto y realmente Qué tanto está
dispuesto a ceder Emanuel macron con
este tema de las pensiones hasta el
momento no quiere ceder no quiere ceder
quiere Mostrar su determinación Pero por
supuesto es un juego un poco peligroso
hay todavía muchas protestas muchos
consentimiento y también una falta de
congruencia entre su política interior
que ha demostrado más autoritarismo
estos escándalos que pueden existir
sobre el uso de la fuerza la falta de
consideración para el parlamento para
los cuerpos intermediarios todos estos
aspectos
contradicen la imagen que in tonto en
los desde su elección promover Macro a
nivel internacional de alguien que lucha
en contra deliberalismo en Europa que se
presenta como un defensor del diálogo
del multilateralismo entonces hay que
tomar en cuenta solamente la degradación
de la situación interna sino también el
impacto internacional de esta crisis
Usted cree que macron está apostando por
el desgaste de las protestas porque ya
llevamos más de dos meses de
manifestaciones al menos una de ellas
semanales ya es hoy la décima gran
jornada de huelga nacional en el país
usted ve que ese desgaste vaya a llegar
bueno
esperar el fin de las protestas
efectivamente la décima jornada de
protesta sin embargo los sindicatos Tal
vez van a proponer una nueva jornada de
protesta si no hay una respuesta por
parte del gobierno todo esto afecta
también la economía afecta también por
ejemplo el turismo Y problemas y
dificultades económicas para muchas
empresas Y entonces veremos lo que
decide hacer si en
de no abrir el diálogo o si acepta abrir
el diálogo pero para abrir el diálogo
tiene que suspender esta reforma la
aplicación de la Reforma de ponciones
porque es una condición absoluta para
los sindicatos que están apoyados por
una gran mayoría de la población de la
opinión pública en particular de los
activos que están en gran mayoría en
contra de esta reforma bien y finalmente
la jornada de ayer la primera ministra
Elizabeth burn que macron además ha
defendido A capa y espada estuvo reunida
con opositores y pues tratando de de
hallar puntos de encuentro no para
llevar adelante pues la gobernabilidad
de macron cuáles podrían ser esos puntos
de encuentro con los parlamentarios para
que sigan avanzando las iniciativas y
que no se caiga además pues la reforma
de las pensiones pues ella ha hablado
sobre todo con los miembros de la
mayoría pero se encuentra en una
situación difícil hay rumores que dicen
que macron podría eventualmente cambiar
de Primer Ministro entonces en la
oposición no hay no podrá haber Muchos
avances probablemente más allá tal vez
de algunos diputados de los republicanos
que están a favor de un acercamiento que
podrían obtener puestos de ministros
pero por el resto no hay imagen de
maniobra para macú su gobernabilidad va
a ser muy complicada porque Más allá de
Elizabeth francesa es un sistema
político muy centralizado sabemos que el
que toma las decisiones las
orientaciones se manualmente
la impopularidad cae sobre Emanuel macu
Y entonces un cambio de gobierno no
podría realmente mejorar mucho la
situación sin un cambio de orientación
política sobre todo si cumple con pues
realizar lo que se dice que sería
eventualmente de nombrar a heraldo
Armando al ministro de del interior que
se hizo famoso por los escándalos de
mentiras al momento de la final de la
Champions League el año pasado que lo
hizo famoso a nivel internacional pues
mire se ve muy complicada la situación
no se ve tampoco una solución y mientras
tanto seguimos con el cubrimiento de las
protestas es
analista internacional profesor de
relaciones internacionales en la
universidad javeriana de Bogotá y
experto en francofonía gracias a usted
gracias por la invitación a nuestros
televidentes sigan en directo América
volvemos con
[Música]